and speaking of power you always like
your chances when wascarinoa takes the
mound for your braves well we said five
days ago very frustrated for him in
colorado he was not happy with the way
he pitched could find the strike zone
but against the nats in three starts
five games in career one-and-oh with the
3-1 so he's done a great job against
them and look for tonight
for wascar bounce-back i just talked
about his outing he needs to have a
going tonight we know he can and then
against fetty continue dominance
and that's outside it's a lead off walk
andy noah walks off the hill a little
frustrated two pretty good pitches as
alcides escobar digs in
and a little chopper hit toward riley
he's gonna have one play
and he makes it it advances the runner
with one out and here is juan soto
ball hit off the pitcher's foot maybe
base hit all the way it was headed up
the middle and then got deadened thomas
to third and soto checks in with his
fifth base hit of this series well there
goes a no hitter juan soto breaking that
thing up early so here's josh homer two
rbis in the series and a big chance for
the nats to bust out on top again
they tried the slider that's well hit to
left center going to plug the gap on a
hop to the wall thomas scores easily
soto held it third by bob henley and the
nets are on the board early again
at truest park josh bell says okay juan
soto now i'm only three rbis behind you
his 20th double he drives in his 79th
run of the year taking that one to the
wall in left center next up yadiel and
with two runners in scoring position a
chance for a big crooked number here and
the pitch breaking ball pulling the
ground up the first baseline fielded by
freeman
they know it coming over he'll take it
himself to the bag as soto comes in from
third to score next up is kibum 2-2
little roller back to the mound taking
on two hops at the foot of the mountain
you know with a bullet over there to
freddie and that's out number three
but the nats pick up two runs two runs
on two hits a walk no errors and one man
left would play to have an inning here
they go against eric fetty who's off and
four
in seven games six starts against the
braves yeah with an 11 era and that's
about to change tonight last starts on
the fourth against the mets took the no
decision and then that's 11-9 loss
against
them that was game one of the double
header seven runs four earned on nine
hits over three innings
and the pitch
swing and a fly ball well hit to left
but yadiel hernandez will gather that in
and ozzy's retired after eight pitches
one man down for jorge solaire and fetty
and they say solaire went around and
he's out on a check swing strikeout so
two up two down freddie freeman bats
with the bases empty the payoff pitch to
freddy freeman
swung on and missed struck him out with
a cutter
and fetty slices right through the
braves in the bottom of the first inning
a 1-2-3 inning complete with two
strikeouts eric fetty's cutter has been
a mystery to this point 30 pitches 19
strikes he's retired the first six in
order
i was going to say that's close and it's
a strike alex tosi ringing up swanson
similar to the pitch on austin riley
last inning another cutter next up the
veteran catcher stephen vogt two balls
at a strike
high fly ball well hit to right soto's
going to turn that ball is gone
steven vogt has hit a home run and the
braves are on the board although that
had to feel good last home run july 11.
that's the 30th home run the braves have
hit against the nationals in 19 games
wow one run game what a battle freeman
and fetty in the fourth
swing in a drive hammer deep left center
field track
lane thomas can't get it ball ricochets
back towards center and freeman stands
at second with a booming double off the
wall somehow freddie was still able to
get that pitch down and in and not pull
it he could tie it with a base hit right
here runner at second one down
hooked over third it's a base hit late
break for freddie they're going to wave
him around
yadiel hernandez drops the ball to the
left and riley in its second with a
game-tying hit got that one just over a
leaping carter key move in third so the
next one will be number 30 in this
inning and number 74 in the game pitch
on the way from betty a lunge in a miss
for strike three it's the curve ball
that takes care of jack peterson that
ends the bottom of the fourth inning but
the braves do get back to back doubles
and a run here's vogue a one out solo
home run in the third inning swing in a
drive deep right center
vote has done it again
a two-home run knight had not had an
extra base hit for the braves and he's
got two homers tonight and the braves
lead three to two sneak attack yeah five
home runs all year hadn't hit one with
the braves until two innings ago
soto who's at third two outs one run
game top six
ki boom takes it the other way and he'll
tie the game he greets chavez with the
base hit to right an rbi single that was
clutch they brought in a pitcher to
match up against him right on right that
picture's right down the middle jorge
soler will lead it off
swing on the first
pitch drill deep center braves are back
in front talk about an impact player
solaire just hit the third solo homer
for the braves tonight way to go jorge
he's hitting eight straight his 23rd
homer that's a big powerful man top of
the order lane thomas will take anything
to get that runner home here with one
out
and that'll get the job done through the
left side and these two teams are
trading jabs here it's now 4-4
and vogt saves another wild pitch or
does he
looks safe at third and he is
thomas to third escobar to second votes
hurt oh he is struggling to get to his
feet oh the back foot came out from
under him as he made the peg and he's
almost appearing to hold back tears
that's going to be it for vote matsix
first
right back off his foot he's going to
hustle try to shovel the plate and they
got
he tried to touch it with his hand
instead of his foot if he goes in with
his foot he's probably safe 4-4 game in
the bottom of the 7th huge opportunity
for the braves right here the pitch
rosario grants one to first zimmerman
has it he comes home they get the force
out there return throw to first with
garcia covering for a double play
nationals turn a three two four double
play for the first two outs in the
bottom of the seventh inning freddie
freeman on deck this inning needs to end
right here for the nats
and look at that deflection garcia's got
a chance and it's a one four three
luis garcia saves the day getting the
deflection off the glove of mason
thompson and a shovel toss with his
glove gets solaire by a step and somehow
the nationals escape the inning without
allowing a run as you know he's often
times one swing away from finding the
magic the 2-2
swaying in a high flat ball he found it
we're tied 5-5 game here in the 8th that
almost reached the roof do you believe
atlanta can the braves outlast the gnats
[Applause]
philadelphia in atlanta
high drama ninth inning tying run at
third go ahead run it first one out
braves up a run
bell
deep short
[Applause]
the ball gets away
so the run will score and josh bell
digging for second the nationals have
tied the game as thomas scores on the
play
can jack peterson be the hero now
there's no margin for error
swag
yeah baby braves win it
that took care of that he's being mobbed
out at second base what a game